we had a question that came in right
here from some gentlemen or or yeah this
fellow right here this happy guy right
here
hey theo my name is brooks long time
listener from florida south carolina
my question for your guest tonight is we
all know that truck stops are the mecca
of the dark arts
what's the craziest thing you've ever
seen go down at a truck stop
thank you for everything you guys both
do love you gang gang
gang brother i'll tell you almost i'll
lead on this one go ahead
so i was going to college
and and i did go and i
went from louisiana and i drove
to uh tucson arizona
and i had worked all summer man to save
up some money so i had me about
hundred dollars in cash and i'd stayed
up
i was up i was doing uppers gas station
uppers no doses
oh yeah you know snorting whatever the
caffeine pill you can get your hands on
oh
i was snorting it yeah dude i did half a
damn mountain dew code
oh i did half of mountain dew code red
straight through one of my nostrils
[Applause]
yeah oh i don't care i'll do it at all
you know
so anyway so i'm up man i've been up for
probably about 20 hours
and my car i had this uh 84
some kind of car i don't know what it
was didn't even matter really it was a
piece of [ __ ] but
um it would overheat so about every
maybe 150 miles it got too hot and so i
had to pull over and wait about 40
minutes for it to go down and then i had
to
make wait for it to cool off so i could
put the water in the uh radiator
radiator
and then go but start back again
well i've been up for [ __ ] a day and
a half man i wasn't doing real well so i
stopped at a truck stop
and uh i guess it was maybe nevada i'm
not sure about or arizona or
west texas somewhere but man i had all
my money and i was like i can't leave it
in my car somebody could break in i'll
leave it on my person right so i
took it put it in my underpants my cash
right so i went into this gas station
i found a place somewhere upstairs they
had like this little lobby kind of place
and i just laid on a bench up there and
just went to sleep
well i slept for about 40 minutes and i
forgot that i had my cash in underpants
when i stood up it just fell out my pant
leg
and i lost all my money no you didn't
lost it all man holy [ __ ] then here's
the shady part
then you're wandering around a gas
station for two and a half hours asking
people if they found twelve hundred
dollars cash right
like they're going to tell you hey yeah
or not
i'll tell you oh sure is it yours would
you like to have it back
none of them are gonna tell you no and
the worst part is they all think you're
on drugs and [ __ ]
oh yeah like you're looking for a piece
of crack you dropped on the ground
like have you found 1200 cash in here
and they're like this dude is on [ __ ]
yeah you want dope man yeah but there
was a question to god asked what the
most dangerous thing was
yeah i did get trash there was a time
when i was doing a pre-trip and it was
in early in the morning sun was out it
was bright
beautiful morning and i was actually
close to the truck stop too
i went out way out in the parking lot
and
it sounds like a bad joke but it's
really not i had my hood open
checking all my fluids checking my belts
everything that needed to be checked
plus i was still green at it so it's
taken me a while to make sure i'm
actually
probably over checking right you're
doing it all right right and here comes
this hispanic guy he wants to know about
how to unplug
the elogs in your truck and i was
telling him oh you go inside of the
storage door of your truck and open it
sometimes you can unplug it
well can you come over here to the truck
and show me i was like no
no i just told you you can go check it
yourself damn so went all about my
business
wiping stuff you know checking here
comes two white dudes
where's your husband at i was like
i said yeah straight straight straight
to it i said he's in there taking a [ __ ]
which i was in there by myself i don't
tell nobody that fake [ __ ] husband trip
yeah and he's like uh really okay
they just stood there and he's talking
amongst themselves i started getting
nervous
and after about 10 minutes you know me
ignoring them
a guy said uh that must be one long [ __ ]
i said he's probably just getting
something to eat since he's [ __ ]
yeah and he finally they've walked up
full of life right there this black guy
a milly vanilli reject oh damn but he's
a big dude
big dude big tall six three muscles
he came in and helped he's got the long
braids he's got one braid hanging in the
front he's like
come over here and give a brother some
love and i was like uh no
i said i got a run to do i drive a truck
you know
and i put the hood down latched them and
started walking over to the driver's
side you know kind of a quick speed
and get in my seat and go to grab the
door
to shut it and he grabs hold of my wrist
no way
and he yanks he ain't so hard that i use
my feet my other hand to hold myself in
the truck
and he's like come and give me some love
and he when he yanked
and i braced and caught myself i grabbed
that yank my
wrist back and shut the door and i was
already trying to put it in gear before
i'd even release the brakes
like i'm really trying to take off and
the truck's like
because the brakes are still on so i had
to release them
took off and trying to peel out of there
on gravel in fourth gear you know with a
heavy truck and it's like
you know trying to take off
and i get down the road and get on the
interstate and broke down and just like
damn near cried damn you know because i
just went limp
this guy just tried to yank me out of
the truck
and it scared the [ __ ] out of me so i
texted on the e-logs of my company
werner
at the time the guy just tried to pull
me out
and sent it and they're like be careful
that's it that's it honey yeah that's
the world baby that's the world be
careful
yeah all right so thanks for the advice
i knew that
appreciate it thank you very much yeah a
lot of guys with those dreadlocks
they'll use them to tie you down oh [ __ ]
i didn't look like he beat you with him
oh yeah
i saw a black guy at the gym he had two
dreadlocks and he was doing them like
those wrote like you know like those
these were long enough they could be
used as lassos oh people doing
you know people don't want around the
throat yeah it's risque out there
yeah it is it's scary baby good evening
good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one
or watch this one watch this one watch
this one watch this one
ah